one of the biggest CS go skin websites
has been targeted in an attack that cost
its owners six million dollars it's the
biggest known hack of a skin website and
instead of targeting a private collector
like in previous thefts it targeted a
major player in the industry it's also
unfortunate to note that a lot of those
skins didn't belong to the site they
belong to users at such a critical
moment for the skin Community we had to
take a look at the potential Fallout
strap yourselves in though this one gets
a little wild
hey guys before we get into the video I
just wanted to ask you to please like
the video If you have a good time and
consider subscribing to the channel and
ringing that notification Bell that way
the next time we've got a story for you
you know right away simple right so if
you're unfamiliar with cs money they are
a skin trading website that was founded
in 2016 during the height of skin Mania
I don't have time to go in depth on the
company's history in this report but
just suffice it to say that they were a
pretty big player before the trade lock
and then afterwards they solidified
themselves as one of the major players
in the industry so there are a lot of
people with opinions about the company
their business model whatever if you try
to go there right now though you're
greeted with this message instead that's
because on Saturday the site security
was circumvented and the result was
millions of dollars in skins leaving the
site's inventory man this graph would
rival some recent crypto crashes if the
y-axis ended at zero all told the
website lost over six million in the
hack with about one third of those skins
belonging to users not the site's owners
now to be fair those numbers are based
on CS money's valuation of the items
which many users continue to hotly
contest still it's a massive hack in a
post by Tim sobolevski Chief
Communications officer of x-corp which
owns CS money he confirmed that the
hackers had compromised the
authenticator date of the company was
using giving them access to their Bots
and their inventories the Skins were
sent to a variety of accounts across
nearly 1 000 trades many of these were
sent to seemingly shell accounts but a
lot of them were just sent to popular
influencers a move that sabolevski says
was designed to throw off the scent
after the first day of the attack the
hackers began to put skins in accounts
labeled CS money Recovery I personally
thought it might indicate a potential
Ransom attempt but sobolevski said he
wasn't so sure sobolevski also confirmed
to me that the attacks against the
website had ceased we are nothing the
middle of another wave if you're asking
about it we hope to relaunch the site as
soon as we will be 100 and one percent
sure that all these pins are safe so
what now what are the chances of these
people actually getting their skins back
both the users and the company let's
break down how these things actually
work so if you use a skin website to buy
sell or trade skins you're probably
doing it with automated Bots it's just a
massive volume of skins that can be
traded these websites have big
inventories there's no way to have
individual people trade all these items
and since steam API allows it you can
just automate these trades the issue is
that it means maintaining a secure
network of accounts to actually hold and
transfer the items and that became more
complicated at the end of the golden age
of skin gambling in early 2018.
essentially valve made it so that if you
receive an item in trade you can't trade
it for a week this was intended to
Target skin gambling but obviously it
also had an effect on skin marketplaces
like CS money with the volume of Trades
going drastically down CS money had to
make changes to their business model
just like all these other marketplaces
but the trade lock also has an impact in
this specific case saboleski explained
that the hackers somehow gained access
to the authentication data for the
accounts they used to trade once the
hackers have that it was easy enough to
start moving skins elsewhere like I said
to Shell accounts or in some cases to
huge influencers some were even being
sent for free to random people who
documented what was happening and CS
money has seemingly reached out to those
people in some cases users realized that
the trades were suspicious and contacted
CS money with the intent to return the
skins once the trade block had expired
this was already a lot more information
about the hack than you might reasonably
assume you'd get from the website that
was targeted but saulboleski told me
that the intent here is to put some
clarity on the situation and improve the
reputation of skin websites as a kind of
gray Market it was always like something
not
not to The Republic let's call it Saul
and usually you don't hear of any public
trading companies on the skin Market
nobody says how much money they're
making we cannot force other people to
say loudly how much money they're making
and so on but at least we believe that
there's nothing there's nothing bad and
send that to your trading teams but that
gray Market designation may make
resolving this whole thing a lot more
complicated let me explain you might
remember that in June a steam account
with a massive two million dollar
inventory was hacked in that specific
case Steam support was responsible for
resetting the account's password which
gave the thief access to the account so
they got involved but I'm not certain we
can expect to see that same kind of
action here for one thing CS money and
skin websites like them are technically
not officially endorsed by Valve to
quote the steam subscriber agreement you
may not use cheats automation software
Bots mods hacks or any unauthorized
third-party software to modify or
automate any subscription Marketplace
process I've never seen any evidence of
valve expressly giving permission for
skin trading Bots although for the most
part they turn a blind eye to it because
it's not like they're actively causing
problems cracking down on skin trading
Bots would be extremely labor intensive
and at the end of the day skin trading
popularizes CS directly and indirectly
the only times that valve has really
gotten involved are cases like op skins
where they advertised helping people get
around the trade block in this case
steam's Restoration policy seems to
state that they won't help and this
isn't some random account with a single
AK Redline in it this is a massive
amount of work to resolve work that
valve would end up paying for in the
case of that June theft I mentioned it
was at least partially valve's fault but
that doesn't seem to be the case here at
least based on the information that we
currently have soboleski didn't want to
comment on whether he thought valve
would get involved but he did confirm
that valve had been contacted but valve
already kind of did CS money a solid
here because the trade lock impedes
these skins from getting very far
wherever they went they can't be moved
for a week before the trade lock those
skins would be long gone laundered
through dozens of marketplaces near
instantly the community too has been a
big help in tracking down where these
skins went it's fair to say that we are
not the most well appreciated guys in
the play this community because we've
been always following our business needs
when we talk about resistance on but in
this particular case everyone has come
and saying okay how can I help and the
people who received since they were like
okay I did that just to save them guys
tell me how to return and so on so forth
and even once they can be moved
sobolevski said that CS money has
already shared information about the
stolen items with some other skin sites
and some have agreed not to touch them
and to ban users who tried to sell them
savilevski also told me that he felt
like the pattern of Trades of the stolen
skins was more designed to deal damage
to CS money than to reap a profit and
certainly like sending out free skins to
random people would fit that pattern all
this situation doesn't look like an
attempt to earn money that those guys
saw this guy or forever was it they
didn't run too much places but they send
the the defender stuff to their films
that were easily found and even the
second wave that they feel there was no
attempt to work and here there's been
zero attempts to connect to us and what
they and what we see is that they just
try to do as much damage as possible the
twit longer from sobolevski also noted
that they can't 100 commit to Future
action although they plan to prioritize
returning user skins and compensating
affected users though there's no telling
when the website will be back online at
this point this probably isn't that
surprising because failing to return
users money in the wake of something
like this would clearly have PR impacts
and at the end of the day there are a
lot of skin marketplaces users have
Choice why would they choose to go to a
place where a bunch of users lost their
skins and they weren't compensated in
any way having said that it's a harsh
lesson for the owners of this site and
maybe all the skin websites out there I
believe that in the future we will see
more actions when Market players will be
United and doing things like this
because like there wasn't much of
lessons like these cases like this in
the past an event like this does have
the potential to Rouse a sleepy giant
like valve to action but even if they
don't act valve will still be making a
choice here it still seems incredibly
unlikely to me that Steam support would
get involved here either to help or to
crack down and if they don't do anything
I feel like most people won't be
surprised but if this is indeed the case
if valve says that's your business with
some other website then users will know
for sure that if their Skins are taken
for whatever reason be it a hack or
something more nefarious even you're
relying on the trading Marketplace to
make it right not valve they're not
coming to help you thankfully it seems
like making this right is a priority for
CS money and for the sites that actually
trade skins this moment could be the
start of something bigger that
cooperation to refuse to accept stolen
skins could actually affect things in
the future if it could be expanded
obviously no one wants more of these
incidents but if you knew that fencing a
stolen skin on some other marketplaces
basically impossible that would probably
reduce the attractiveness of actually
doing that ultimately my main concern is
that the people who lost skins get their
stuff back beyond that I'll be watching
for the Fallout and if there's any other
update in this story maybe I'll see you
again
man this graph would rival some recent
crypto crashes if the x-axis ended in
zero or wait it's wide it's the y-axis
bro I was I was gonna get roasted in the
comments bro I was about to get in
typical Humanities student doesn't know
the the y-axis but you know what the
thing about this is we're talking about
it now and this is gonna end up in the
bloopers so then people are gonna be
like
ha like they're gonna do the [ __ ]